je vais parler politique
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais ok on se calme on n'est pas
là pour dire pour qu'il faut voter dans
x années on est là parce qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai envie qu'on fasse une petite
rétrospective de tous les moments de
politiques en france qui nous ont fait
kiffer pas ceux qui ont été très très
connu les trois cas d'erreur année qui
sont même devenus des mêmes comme ou
encore missions dans les campagnes dans
les vous mêmes
non non non non ça on a déjà tout vu
aujourd'hui on est là pour voir des
moments similaires mais qui sont
pluvieuse donc que vous n'avez peut-être
pas vu mais qui sont tout autant géniaux
attention je précise les amis on n'est
pas là pour parler de ses opinions
politiques pour ce qu'on nous y en a pas
qui n'ont pas d'ailleurs née juste là
pour voir des gens qui sont mystifié
parce qu'il représente un pays on attend
d'eux qu'ils se comportent mais comme
les meilleurs des sommes qu'ils nous
fassent surtout pas honte mais des fois
ça foire et moi c'est ce moment là que
je vois aujourd'hui c'est lé moment vous
sachiez ya un truc à aller de travers et
c'est ça qui fait rien nous allons
commencer avec chirac avec jacques
chirac [ __ ] je parle comme si tu es
mon pote c'est horrible quel homme fort
on dirait mon grand-père des trucs
drôles de jacques chirac la fois où il
était à la république de la coupe du
monde le public crier les noms des
joueurs un à un et jacques chirac
voulait lui aussi avoir ce plaisir de
crier le monde des joueurs sauf qu'ils
connaissaient pas trop les noms jacques
chirac
au début on ne peut pas dit non mais pas
du tout il fait vraiment ça et ça passe
sur tous les noms la frc
[Applaudissements]
elle connaissait pas on a du pain sur la
table deux ans
[Applaudissements]
tu ne peux pas ça ne marche pas dans la
vie quand tu ne connais pas un bon tu
peux pas ne rien dire et juste la
dernière syllabe faire comme si tu l'as
vécu ici on a un micro devant la bouche
on entend juste ça ça ne marche pas
jacques alors as we are celle là elle
est exceptionnelle je l'avais vu à
l'époque chirac est un homme qui aime
les femmes comme beaucoup d'hommes est
ce qu on lui en veut pour ça bernadette
chirac devait faire un discours devant
des gens je sais pas pour quelle
occasion je sais pas dans quel but mais
bon là devait faire un discours et donc
j'en étais assis derrière elle il ya une
dame jeunes qui ne trouvaient pas de
place pour s'asseoir et chirac est
trouvé ça scandaleux qu'elle ait pas de
place pour s'asseoir et il a insisté
pour qu'elle s'assoit à côté de lui et
ce qui se passe ensuite est fabuleux
mesdames et messieurs les élus mais
chacun si j'avais su je tenais à fond
pour cette unis et elle le reprend
vraiment aucun devant tout le monde
regardait maven qui commencent à sortir
c'est que j'apprécie vraiment ce moment
voilà c'est un indicateur d'appréciation
de moment sa tête jacques on l'a tous
fait qu'on avait 9 ans ont copié sur le
voisin avec le prof nous prend en train
de copier sur le voisin mais tu l'as
fait à 60 piges c'est drôle jacques
situe rien de cette vidéo ben toi débat
présidentiel jacques chirac et face à
mitterrand mitterrand qui sort de son
quinquennat jacques chirac qui est le
premier ministre qu'est ce que jacques
chirac va dire à mitterrand ce moment là
comme été moins juste de vous dire que
ce soir je ne suis pas le premier
ministre et vous n'êtes pas le président
de la république nous sommes deux
candidats à égalité et qu'ils se
soumettent au jugement des français
seuls qui comptent
vous me permettrez donc de vous appeler
monsieur mitterrand vous avez tout à
fait raison monsieur le premier ministre
mais réponse il à travers les produits
des hommes politiques ils ont une impro
fin à l'époque en tout cas maintenant
c'est un peu moi où je trouve qu'on
regarde mais je trouve que ça par
exemple c'est vraiment c'est un clash
coiffeur limité à paris avec un panneau
round 1 et le but c'est de sortir la
plus grosse
punchline enfin le plus gros bazar le
plus de voix ça me fait rire moyennant
un autre moment où jacques chirac a fait
des folies mais ça c'est les vidéos
principal et ce qui est bien en voyant
ça c'est qu'on a un peu moins peur de
vieillir
on espère dans 20 30 en parler de cette
manière à voir ce charisme
deuxièmement nous allons passer à
sarkozy à monsieur nicolas sarkozy et
alors lui il a aussi fait des trucs mec
c'est fou y aurait des millions
affichant un peu le tir d'essai de son
jeune âge et tu crois que si tu craques
sur l'insultant qui tue pas réglés pour
les pêcheurs c'est à dire il est vener
viala à la castagne vas tu vas voir g
président si tu crois que sur la
substance du cube à régler pour les
pêcheurs ceci dit il a pas tort sur la
deuxième partie de la phrase insultes et
ne résout aucun problème vraiment une
fois j'ai insulté ma maman et ben
vraiment le problème a été décuplée
vidéo suivante il s'agit d'un vol de
stylos apparemment notre président et sa
collection bling bling qui grossit à vue
d'oeil et l'abbé déjà les chaînes en or
les grosses montres l'alliance et lundi
en roumanie
il n'a pas résisté en signant un
partenariat stratégique regardez bien
est pas mal le stylo qui brille qui leur
oppose
il revient dessus le prends demande au
président roumain et un truc bing bling
deux coups devant la preuve la raison
mais moi je fais pareil qu'un stylo
plume poivre blanc ah bah moi en classe
là tout ce débat grosse comme ça pour
rien le mans le plus connu ou sarko
s'est foiré en public c'est après le g8
c'est à dire ces rassemblements de huit
pays pour discuter des échanges
économiques etc
entre sarkozy vient rencontrer poutine
la rencontre a duré je crois une ou deux
heures et en sortant de la rencontre il
fait un discours du coup devant des
journalistes français qui lui disent
alors avec la russie on et comment
est-ce que de relations vont être bien
etc
et sarko est complètement tort chez tout
le monde se dit ah bah c'est poutine la
russie la vodka ça y est il a descendu
des trucs sarko à écouter c'est
impressionnant je vous demande de bien
vouloir excuser leurs auteurs
qui est dû la longueur des dialogues que
j'en à voir avec monsieur poutine
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous préférez je réponds
aux questions alors
y at il des questions on ici hier
documenta qui sortit plus tard sur sa
qui revenait sur cette rencontre entre
sarkozy et poutine etc expliqué qu'en
fait sarkozy à la sortie la rencontre il
avait vis-à-vis pas du tout vu les deux
il n'était pas du tout bourré sauf que
poutine l'avait remis à sa place mais
avec une force monumental sarkozy par la
poutine un peu dernier retard sur deux
lui bla bla bla poutine salle un peu
saoulé et poutine et regarder ça qu il a
dit écoute moi bien mec ton pays c'est
ça mon pays c'est ça donc maintenant tu
vas commencer à changer ton sinon je
vais t'écraser et du coup il était comme
ça pendant le discours donc sachez que
si vous faites très fortement humilié
quand vous parlez après vous ressembler
à ça donc peut-être marquer une pause de
30 minutes entre l'humiliation et le
moment vous parlez pour voilà éviter de
vivre sarraut soit hollande président de
2012 à 2017 alors déjà lui il représente
parfaitement le niveau d'anglais moyens
que les français aient ou non mais
vraiment serre tels clichés
ça méritait d'être président s'accroche
et story
vous savez c'est l'hôtesse que notre
dieu à tous
dion special fusée oil & gas est ce
qu'on peut en vouloir aux landes arrêté
on fait tout ça bouillonne serviette
quand le mot il sort pas et cas le
moment de silence qui se prolonger plus
prolonge plus tu es mal à l'aise balle à
tuchan le moins français bon mois pour
casser sa hauteur veut pas hollande
manuel valls manuel valls qui était le
premier ministre quand françois hollande
était président de la république une
fois il est passé sur france inter et il
a eu une attitude trop bizarre
c'est un reptilien il avait entamé sa
transformation il a su se ressaisir au
dernier moment en regardant derrière lui
et ensuite on s'est marré qui fait
baisser la température du corps on n'est
pas passé loin d'un reptilien la
présidence ah oui une autre fois aussi
la fin d'un discours à l'assemblée sa
main gauche tremblé énormément pendant
le discours est tout le monde a remarqué
ça et les gens savaient pas trop quoi en
penser
voilà par exemple elle perdu l'un
derrière ségolène elle est perdue il a
des attitudes des fonds publics qu'il
faut un peu flipper et même et là je
trouve qu'il a une tête de méchant dans
les films alors il est temps que dans ce
pays il y avait débat et déchire devoir
alors madame jusqu'au bout
je me raccompagne pour finaliser et pour
vous dites vous
hier fois
[Musique]
alors jégo ou juste pas quelqu'un par sa
tête mais ça m'inspire pas confiance
quand un homme politique telle manière
qu il est temps maintenant de parler
d'un personnage que j'adore parce qu'on
a l'impression qu'il a rien à faire là
qui s'est perdue s'est retrouvé là il
s'amuse jean lassalle alors lui mais qu
il a fait tellement de moments où il
c'est n'importe quoi mais je trouve que
l'action du sud ça rend les gens sympas
alors même si des fois ils parient
misogyne sa mère et ben on n'arrive pas
à lui en vouloir et ça c'est un problème
déjà au oui oh oui ça je sais ce que
c'est juste ça c'est fou la parole
monsieur sarkozy président mesdames et
messieurs les députés le premier
ministre vient il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît ont prévu de toi il a patienté
dans un ami
monsieur thomas schaaf à lui monsieur
lui c'est vous pouvez vous asseoir s'il
vous plaît est ce qu'un jour quelqu'un
pensait qu'à l'assemblée quelqu'un
dirait cette phrase asseyez vous et ça
c'est de chanter mes hobbies ou là on
est dans une classe d'école de 6e ou
quoi et patrick chan préféré mon cochon
préféré c'est une petite [ __ ]
à saint-paul épouse il a rigolé presque
cinq secondes à sa propre blague
qu'est ce que j'aimerais pouvoir faire
ça
et
mais voilà il aurait pu faire carrière
dans la chanson il est à l'assemblée il
voit des gens dans lui ça lui fait
penser une salle de concert islami
champix un artiste voilà ce que c'est
jean lassalle je suis pas la commenter
celle-là oui que celle du couple non
c'est ma mère est alors tu arrêtes avec
les femmes ah non tu les laisses jean
lassalle doit terminer lettre merci
beaucoup jean lassalle merci à vous mais
mme thériault heureuse qui ferait pas le
mois gentil merci beaucoup
la présidentielle ça continue mesdames
faites gaffe à jean lassalle a quand
même allez on passe à un autre
j'appelle françois bâillon un jour il
rendait visite à une mairie d'un
quartier défavorisé me semble sa chance
à et sachant qu'ils avaient une caméra
et des jeunes qui ont lancé des pierres
sur une vitre de la mairie pour qu'elle
se pète et donc françois bayrou sort de
la mairie et parle à ses jeunes et mais
qui fait un truc exceptionnel mais pas
dans le sens du tout pendant la
discussion quelques enfants se masse
autour du candidat
attendez je remets la scène j'ai pas
bien vu
[Applaudissements]
l'incident n'ira pas plus loin
ok je ris pas pour la jfp qui ce très
grave mais pour tout ce qu'il ya autour
si génial déjà est-ce que ce gosse qu'il
faisait vraiment les poches
on saura jamais il est possible qu'il
ait sorti un gros mytho ou alors qu'ils
aient cru que le gardien faisait les
poches alors que non mais le plus fou
c'est lui l'occident n'ira pas plus loin
on dirait qui vient de voir un but de la
france en finale de coupe du monde alors
que drucker je suis de voir son pot de
se faire gifler par nos politiques c'est
quoi cette réaction avec les dames
l'un d'eux il ne faut pas dire le nom
sous peine de bad buzz immédiat alors
lui mais qu'il a fait un nombre de
trains c'est un truc de malade
les 100 fois plus connu pour ses gaffes
que pour ses idées politiques a vraiment
regarder ça est ce que vous voyez des
aspects positifs à l'immigration qui
était la question
le deuxième partie de séance incertain
change oui quand c'est quand c'est bien
sûr si c'est léonard de vinci c'est sûr
c'est faire courir moitié
je vais te faire courir moiroud qu'un
[ __ ] heureusement heureusement ça c'est
aujourd'hui c'est impossible mais
heureusement que moi j'offre un débat
monsieur mélenchon lui retirer son
caleçon
ça me dépasse je sais pas quoi dire
comment tu peux dire ça quand tu es dans
le politique games est fou à trouver du
terme dans les cheveux de madame ce
qu'il faut parler d' appeler les choses
par leur nom dans les cheveux de madame
diallo
il n'est pas venu comme ça c'est pas un
shampoing de shampoing strauss kahn bon
en fait je ris pas parce que c'est drôle
en soit ce qu'il dit je ris parce que
c'est la seule réaction face à ce que je
vois ça me dépite profondément
dentifrice et par chambre
voilà on sait le shampoing strauss kahn
n'a
nous les amis j'ai trop vu de moments
politiques pour l'année reste pas mal de
ciel vous a plu j'espère que ça ne
partira pas en guerre d'opinion dans les
commentaires on n'est pas là pour ça y'a
des forums si vous voulez vraiment je
compte sur vous pour maintenir la bonne
ambiance qui a généralement de les
commentaires de mes vidéos moi en tout
cas j'avais envie de montrer des trucs
qui sont moins connus auprès de nous et
des plus jeunes même que moi parce que
je trouve ça intéressant je trouve ça
marrant ça démystifier un peu le truc et
puis si ça permet à des gens de
s'intéresser derrière à l'homme
politique
tant mieux c'est bien il ya plein plein
plein plein d'hommes politiques donc
j'ai pas parlé là parce qu'il n'y avait
rien d'incroyable sur eux je n'ai pas
fait des choix pour influencer mon
public ou chez papa non puisque la vraie
mort c'est un sujet tellement table
clément adultes ou fait pas ce montage
[Musique]
coût
oh
jacques chirac
[Musique]